je suis désolé d'avoir fait ça mais je
n'en pouvais plus les insultes matin et
soir des moqueries des menaces
je n'en peux plus et j'ai envie d'en
finir
mais rien ne les arrêtera car malgré
tout ce qui s'est passé elle me voudront
toujours du mal pardon maman je suis
parti rejoindre papa parce que son père
est décédé elle avait 3 ans
et j'espère de tout cœur que ce que j'ai
fait aura servi à quelque chose
je pense que ce que j'ai fait va les
réjouir elle penseront qu'elles ont
gagné et arrêter tout ça
je ne pouvais même pas me confier au
directeur car il était avec elle
il ne voulait rien
donc la seule chose que je pouvais faire
était de partir
faites attention à Maëlys à ce qui
pourrait lui arriver faites attention à
vous je vous aime au revoir
c'est bouleversant et puis elle a le
courage dans sa détresse de de penser de
manière prémonitoire à Maëlys
j'ajouterai juste que la famille qui
tenait une conférence de presse à porter
plainte pour non assistance personne en
danger contre le principal du collège
contre l'académie de Lille contre les
policiers qui ont recueilli les plainte
au début et contre Instagram et Facebook
mais moi je veux dire il faut que ça
bouge de quoi j'ai peur c'est que ça
bouge pas encore qui se passe rien il
faut que ça ah oui bah c'est ça
comment ça se passe
exactement les mêmes les mêmes mots elle
en a parlé au directeur et en fait il la
laisse il la laisse elle m'a même dit
ils ont voulu la pousser dans l'escalier
cette personne qui était derrière moi
justement au cortège elle a voulu la
pousser dans l'escalier la dernièrement
donc je lui ai dit tout de suite
j'allais prendre rendez-vous avec ses
parents pour agir vite quoi parce qu'on
a pris le temps en fait clairement
problème c'est que ça se passe toujours
à l'intérieur quand on a l'extérieur
nous on est un peu bloqué parce que bah
la police
comme ça se passe à l'extérieur je vais
pas intervenir c'est le sentiment
d'impunité qu'elles ont ces jeunes
filles et par ailleurs que le décès de
de l'Insee ne les ai pas chamboulé enfin
c'est à dire qu'elle continue et c'est
exactement ce qu'a dit l'INSEE
et là est-ce qu'elle dit elle penseront
qu'elles ont gagné mais penser qu'elle a
elle est
au contraire pas du tout mais c'est
bouleversant je trouve qu'elle a une
maturité incroyable dans ce qu'elle dit
et ce qui est terrible c'est qu'on se
dit que ce drame était prévisible en
fait parce qu'elle savait que il y avait
rien à faire du côté de l'école que le
directeur était avec elle comme elle le
dit donc ça met d'autant plus l'école
dans une situation délicate parce qu'ils
auraient dû anticiper cette situation
c'est moi la mairie de l'éducation avant
de parler de de d'école de de de
d'administration de de juridique tout ça
voilà de plainte etc je me dis le
directeur il est c'est quand même désolé
est-ce qu'il peut encore se regarder
dans une glace tous les matins est-ce
qu'il peut comment il peut encore aller
là-bas allez bosser faire le malin et
aller bosser et se regarder tous les
jours dans une glace et se dire
les procès les trucs bien sûr que c'est
très important parce que je veux que la
famille de l'Insee veut que la lumière
soit faite sur cette affaire et qui est
des gens qui sont les parents
d'arthologie
extrêmement émouvant je trouve dans
cette lettre c'est que en fait elle
s'est elle s'est elle s'est suicidée
pour que ça bouge en fait et ça bouge
pas c'est ça qui dingue elle s'est dit
si je ne fais pas ça il a rien se passer
donc ça commence à bouger parce que vous
vous en parlez on en parle sur TPMP etc
voilà on a des témoignages comme madame
qui fait quelque chose avec les motards
donc il se passe quelque chose
médiatiquement ça commence un petit peu
à bouger mais enfin c'est c'est
largement pas suffisant
c'est quoi ce gang de petite conne les
quatre là c'est c'est 4 katchi qui qui
l'a plus
d'effet de masse qui est en fait
inarrêtable c'est comme un effet boule
de neige quand ça commence comme ça
c'est difficile de s'extraire du lot